the time so it was like so then
he was
i agree with you though a lot of [ __ ]
was promised we were supposed to be in
first class we were supposed to be on
and it just didn't happen a lot so
aren't so on the flight home and how
long is that flight 16 hours 17 17 hours
okay
we get to the airport and i get coach
middle scene
for 17 hours he has um i have panic
attacks so i there's just no way i was
like i guess i'm going to live here in
uh
beirut yeah i mean but there's another
little part of the story let me have to
step in there
okay go ahead this is the part you
forget
bobby decides to pay the three thousand
dollars to upgrade himself to first
class of course he does he does it still
so he he pays the money and he walks to
first class like this see ya [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then the credit card was denied
so he had to come back
oh yeah
had to come back with his tail between
his legs after he already was like you
know he had that moment of life fear
bobby lee victory yeah yeah he did the
dismount
yeah yeah i remember that and then i
came back you came back and i was having
a panic he was crushed and eric griffin
goes listen man i have an aisle
you can have my aisle i'll sit in the
middle wow
17 hours as soon as he said i'm about to
get emotional as soon as he said that
that's it
best friends forever not just he is
a life
guy you're a man and by the way
even after him being a complete [ __ ]
but i saw that this was going to be a
thing for him and i was like still
there's a thing because um
it's cool few months ago um his travel
agent made the mistake and he got the
same seat a center um a middle seat and
he basically said i'm going to cancel
the whole gig yeah i'm with you on that
yeah i'm going to cancel the whole
[ __ ] gig
and i'm going to get off the [ __ ]
plane right now through an absolute [ __ ]
fit
because i'm going to tell you why though
baby okay it's this okay we hope you're
panicked that's not that no
i want to be honest with you man new
york really [ __ ] me up that's why i'm
a little weird right now
i'm going to be real with it i didn't
have some good shows in new york what do
you consider not a good show because
i've seen you there was nine people in
my third show i wasn't gonna say
anything because i'm embarrassed by it i
think that we can talk about this it's a
reality i have to confront my reality
it was a 12 30 show midnight it doesn't
matter what all the details though so
what about the details though it's one
of my characters thank you so can i just
say this okay this is that i
know that my ticket numbers since
january have been amazing you've sold
out every single yeah yeah amazing
but dude it's like
saturday night new york 12 30 there was
nine people
and then i walked up to the manager and
i go hey
do i have to do 45 minutes
because yeah you still have to do a show
yeah i go can we cancel it no
contractually though i i get that
because those people did pay
22 dollars to see you so of course
that's they were all tiger belly fans
thank god that's good you're amazing and
um
and without them obviously
there'd be no show so i thank you for
coming out but dude it was really
humbling my question is you know in
anticipation if let's say i'm like a
club owner and i see that oh only nine
people have bought tickets for a 12 30
show wouldn't i just cancel that show
inform those nine people but that
there's an earlier show with still nine
seats available
shut down the club early and you know
save money on electricity on not paying
you know they have shows downstairs
that's why
i see so right so the things open right
already you know and it's also it's like
you know that's the comedy
that's what i'm going to say is that
it's comedy it's life and it's new york
there's a lot of competition and it's
not that it's just that like it's just
like oh
it's just like you know 20 years
you know i mean i've done this game you
know
and i just need a little reprieve
you know it's like every year it's like
audition not getting it this that and
then your friends become you know and
then it's like you just want a little
reprieve
you just went a little like a year where
you're just kind of like you know
you know i'm fine you know
but every year is a [ __ ] battle it's
like every day it's a battle
you know
and it's like other i'm just gonna say
it it's like
you know what bobby what man up
close sniper tonight what wow
man up baby sack the [ __ ] up
put your [ __ ] in you make good money
you have a roof over your head
you have me you have friends you have
tiger belly you have your three cats
we're good we get fed all right life is
all right yeah i wasn't really crying by
the way but way by the way okay i was
just doing a fake cry it's called acting
you know i was called acting guys yeah
showcasing my abilities you know
i want to read this to you
i said this
my dear friend
and comedy collaborator whoa gilbert
gallon cologne is trying to get an
audition for mad tv
i wouldn't ask if i didn't think he was
the greatest thing since me
he's filipino and young and super
talented
is represented by principal
entertainment
la matt berkel
also i'd love to get involved any way i
can with the show thanks
denny goes it is arranged bobby thank
you right
so that's what i said all right
if you go in there tomorrow and [ __ ] the
bed
that goes down the toilet can i say i i
don't care if you're scared i don't care
if you guys think that i'm being [ __ ]
up right now not bringing it up look at
me right now i want you to [ __ ] get
the job
all right he will so man up
step into it and get this [ __ ] job
can i say it don't be scared i'm not i'm
trying to look at me right now i say
this yeah
i'm saying because i know you hate one
to see you're already smiling go ahead
thank you
are you two crying right now yeah you
look like your body i'm about to cry
cause i might hug you
thank you thank you no thank you
no
thank you not
thursday please don't fall
close it got close it got closed right
yeah i got close but that's what i
[ __ ] sent but no i will always yeah i
will always pride i will always i
believe you i believe in you i did it
and the whole weekend was great i got to
know tom seguro really well and let me
say my [ __ ] opinion about tom segura
he is a 10.
and i'm about to cry oh
he's a good dude his special is my
favorite of the year was it last year
he's a good dude
another [ __ ] i'm going to tell you
another person right
wally wong
wally wong or no ali
ali wong yeah i'm about to cry [ __ ]
good girl man you guys go way back too
we go way back you know but
um to see how
much she has grown
is really just an amazing thing to see
and i love asian comedy as you know that
fan number one
one of my faves was dynamic was he there
no oh okay
well aren't you the only comic that
didn't have a car to pick you up to at
from the airport yeah yeah what
so i show up and there's i have to take
now a cab a yellow cab and everyone has
limos jesus right
and this is why i i love tom
i'm outside
and he could should have because you
know first class they leave the flight
i'm the last seat so as soon as i get
off the flight they're gone and there's
nobody which i wanted yeah
so i'm slowly getting through i go
outside
tom segura waited for me he goes i don't
think you have a ride do you
no
no that's what i heard
and i said no yeah and he goes i'll give
you a ride
and he gave me a ride
and the um
he did that a couple of times man
and then um
and then after austin saturday night
they invited me to dinner it was me i
ali tom segura
and uh an agent and
um jermaine fowler i love him too
you know jimmy faller
yeah yeah he's a skinny little he's not
that skinny yeah he's very scary he's
kind of handsome he's very handsome
black guy yeah yeah
yeah he's young he just got on a show i
don't know what it was but he him and i
shared a room
all our dressing room was just me and
oh i thought you meant shared hotels
damn your finances are yeah yeah but i
just want to say that i want to say
that the whole thing was great and i
just anyone listening right now if
you're if you like tom segura like him
more yeah i feel like i'm sorry you know
i don't know why i'm so confrontational
today he he is his
his masculinity and his um it's
threatening it is threatening
i know you're acting like a wild i know
and i and i i feel like
i was in a corner and i have nothing i
don't even know why i'm defending other
things you know what in a zombie
apocalypse let's just be friends and
let's try to survive you can be the
leader if you want to okay all right all
right
zombie apocalypse
but um there's only room for one person
in the event i'm gonna be in
yeah don't laugh because you're going to
be the you're going to be a zombie for
sure i'll probably you're weak
but you're weak on every level my friend
his stand up is pretty good i can only
kick from a distance yeah i just no
okay you're a zombie
and also can i say this i wouldn't even
kill you if you're a zombie why i'll
chop your arms off and you'd be like one
of those things
like michelle michonne
so i just wait i'd be your pet yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] up that's weird man don't
don't worry i wouldn't let bobby do that
to you
i'll jump into his group go there you go
all right let's uh let's do a vault
let's do a ball
let's do a [ __ ] ball all right in a
zombie apocalypse all right and
cameraman there's going to be no
hostility towards you all right but me
and eric have two different [ __ ]
survival teams you talk about like your
so yeah raise your hand who's going to
be with eric we'll give you a little bit
of like what's going on
you have to sell yourself sell your
tribe all right i'm gonna sell the
situation okay here's the currency okay
um
where we're at we live on a street right
here so in the building that we're in is
where i'm in okay and the building run
across is where eric is everything else
is zombified
okay all right you have to make a choice
who you're going to be with
clan you're going to clan with
all right so raise your hand eric be
real
okay yeah everyone
go ahead babe
be real she's gonna stick with her man
dude all right all right so
these two guys saw the two cameramen the
two cameraman you
yeah all right all right who's gonna be
with me you know what [ __ ] we're both
gonna die i'm gonna die with my
childhood to start watching tv and you
know what i kind of just said thing
right now
you're forever my friend for a while yes
in fact you know what dude you just went
up so high with me
you really you you [ __ ]
[Music]
what could go with him he'll [ __ ] you
anyway
uh that really meant a lot to me happy
birthday thanks man yeah you want a
dinner tonight i'll pay whatever
whatever you want whatever you want you
know
[ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you i'm sorry babe am i going out
of control right now out of control i
love it is it too much
no i think it'll level down or what i
don't know it's up to you you're the
captain of the ship i am the captain of
the ship let me say something right now
okay let me say something right now um
i believe that
and let's go back to pastor gail let's
get spiritual again
i believe that everything happens for a
reason there's no coincidences
we're together here for a reason we were
all meant to be we here at this very
moment
and
i heard your point of view
i heard how you feel
oh no these guys oh about the thing
we're still at that thing no no no no no
no i want to get spiritual let's get
let's get down to the real braxton taxes
braxton taxes all right
i we're here
we're in this moment
and you just showed me your true self
you two especially
and i hear you and i accept it but let
me say something right now
that is why we can never
[ __ ] we can never be close
okay and that is the reason why paulie
treated you like [ __ ]
for three [ __ ] years and that's it
for the other day until yeah for the
year yes you do a new year's show
anywhere no a comedy story by the time
we're going to be taking a break too um
over the holidays
and for two weeks
yeah i mean
and then we'll resume in the new year
yeah we'll have some but i want to say
this though and i
and and i want you to really listen to
me
everyone listening
i truly believe
that this podcast
reinvented my life
i'm about to cry
you are crying
it
it connected me to the people that are
real for fans of mine
and um
it's just been an unbelievable adventure
you know i'm sorry i couldn't hold my
sneeze that's the rudest [ __ ] thing
this man is crying [ __ ] [ __ ] you this
man is crying i'm done i'm out she
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and she adapted she
dabbed in the middle sorry
i couldn't hold it i made a mistake
these fans have changed my oh god
sorry dad
daddy yes sir that real quick but were
your parents at your when you were
delivering were they there uh no they
weren't i just wanted bart in there i
didn't know what i did were they were in
the hospital they weren't even in the
building uh they were no they weren't
cause it was like at four in the morning
like you you can't really time it you
can't be like hey you can't time it i'm
gonna pop this [ __ ] seven o'clock you
better do yours late at night in the
morning what if i won't be there
i will
yeah i'll get i'll hire somebody i'll
give you money i'll give you a hundred
bucks i'll look alike that actually
might be better for me because you get
frazzled and freaked out and it might
your energy might transfer over onto me
i don't know if i'm going to be a good
dad
it's going to be awesome because of this
[ __ ] guy i've been trying to test my
heart right here
with him no this is their dog
so embarrassing but then that's when i
knew that he was playful but here's when
i knew that i really liked him and that
he was a good guy is is that
apparently we were supposed to arrange
our own rides
from the airport we're in austin yeah to
the hotel right
and everyone got off the plane first
class you know when your friends are in
first class and you're in coach you
would think that they would wait for you
to deplane wasn't ally on the flight too
yeah yeah right
no one did straight into their limos
they went right into their limos that
they their people set up i don't have a
limo enough i don't know how i'm going i
don't even know where i'm staying
all right
so i'm like walking i don't see anybody
and i walk outside
and i see tom standing there with his
limo driver
and he says i just assumed that
you don't have a ride
and i go correct correct
i'll give you a ride to the hotel
who [ __ ] i don't know who i'm about to
cry who the [ __ ] does that
i mean
no let me get
who does that
i mean not only
we're not war buddies
we weren't nom together
yeah i wish i was you know
but um i don't know him that much
i don't know him
and he does that that's [ __ ] dope bro
like i i would probably hurt somebody
for you thanks buddy you're welcome
wonderful guy
do you know what i thought i remembered
though tell me if i'm wrong about this
yeah i did make the assumption you
didn't have the car and i waited yeah
didn't you
come down and go like oh like where's my
car oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
like
is my guy here
i was like did you book a guy yeah
yeah yeah i was like that you don't have
a guy oh i i mean a normal community
would have fired his [ __ ] people from
no dude they just no it's no they
they've they hung me out to dry
then we had a good talk on the way oh
you know what i do but can i just say
something
i want to say this baby
that um there's a lot of things i would
have never done without you and i'm glad
i did those things
it's beautiful that's beautiful yeah um
what else what do we do
like dolphin swimming we haven't done
dolphins remember that one time you made
me swim out there and i got stung by a
thousand jellyfish oh that's right
other koreans are like what do you think
will happen next yeah what's your next
boyfriend if we break up
uh well let me think about this um
i've basically dated every single race
really but i haven't done a new yorker
indian guy and i've been eyeballing them
lately really yeah
like off the boat indian no i knew you
an indian raised in new york oh i got
you not an ellie his parents let's say
are indian but he's raised in new york
but not i'm not saying aziz but like you
know just that flavor kind of right uh
the east coast yeah indian oh go for it
i've never done that i mean i'm not you
know
just i'm just throwing it out there yeah
yeah
i mean i think ask me dude ask me
well you're back to white chicks i know
you're done with asian no be real ask me
okay bobby what's next nothing you're
done
i really believe that oh well then i'm
[ __ ] done too bro you asked me the
question i i i
i truly believe that without her
it's i can't there's nothing
yeah this would be there's no east coast
indian
[ __ ] this would be the most amazing
time for you to leave him like right now
yeah yeah
as he's like this is you mean
you're like i just want to do it
in new york i thought you were giving me
an opening with that question i just
said no no no
no i honestly believe if she something
happened to her yeah or you know she
laughed i honestly it would take me a
decade
i think because we're fully attached at
no it's not even that it's just that
i just
to to get to know somebody again and to
know that would be horrible
all the little things and this and that
we're not a super like lovey dovey kind
of like showy
kind of couple yeah um and i really like
that i think previously i dated guys
that were just really like mushy and
sweet and they were nicely super
codependent but [ __ ] just like every
text good morning sweet i just [ __ ]
my vagina just turned to dust every
morning you know like when we we have
sex she just rolls over
there's no there's no
guy making sound like a [ __ ] robot no
but she just rolls over and just like
dead eyes no i look at you no i look at
you i look
deeply into his eyes that was disgusting
no that's not yeah and um i love it yeah
you do love it yeah i don't think i
heard a towel or nothing
but anyway hey good to see you i love
you back to the life warrior so you're a
life warrior i'm alive so we did three
things three things okay each one
very difficult the first place we go to
first of all we're with a guy named hugo
who's the best he's a guide or he's a
guide okay
and
i miss him so much
i'm gonna emotional
um you know you meet people
in life
no matter what country you're on and you
just kind of go yeah
if we lived in the same town that dude
would be my friend or somebody that i
would really know
you know he
he's also
the mayor of tulum i mean everywhere we
went
like cab drivers
street walkers people would just come
like hey what's up and he would like
they would hug him or he was a handshake
he was the best this guy
yeah you know i got a really nice
message from someone today i'm gonna get
real how about this bobby i'm listening
to you okay
that's why i close my eyes i'm listening
go ahead i got a very nice message today
on instagram uh messenger right from a
young man who said he'd been living
listening to the show
from the age of 13 now he's 19 years old
and he said uh it's really shaped my
sense of humor blah blah blah i said a
lot of really nice things and he was
really
i i wrote him back you know you try to
write these people back when they say
something when they just you know when
they share that hey you've done this
thing and i've listened to it and here's
how it's affected me i think a small
percentage of people are obviously
reaching out so it's important to go to
you know thank the guy for doing
caring and for reaching out and he was
very well spoken and he said he said
nice things and i don't want to you know
but i told you i was getting serious and
he goes uh
i think he could probably pick up
listening to the show
all right here's the truth i feel like i
have no idea
what my
i feel like i have no idea and maybe
we've sort of talked about this because
i don't do stand up yeah yeah how i
don't ever get to the point no
um i feel like i have no idea what the
value is out there
for some of the dumb things that i do
because this guy was definitely is
definitely picking up on the on the
podcast that i'm very you know i'm
playing around but i'm definitely like
ah [ __ ] it you know whatever here goes
the podcast it's gone here's a dumb
wrestling joke and blah blah and the
diamonding this and that we want less
listeners and all this [ __ ] and those
who are left you guys are our diamonds
you're the ones who get every [ __ ]
joke we value you more as you as your
you know compatriots fall off the side
uh this guy picked up on that and was
like hey
you know this whatever the nice things
he said and he goes that's something to
be proud of will yeah i don't think
pride has any uh place in
comedy or
uh
entertainment i think it's a i think
it's a poison
right yeah don't you think
you even saying it
humans saying it
you saying what you just said yeah
struck a chord with me just now yeah
yeah i've never really thought of it
that way but you are correct pride has
no place in it don't pretend to cry i'm
not
[ __ ] you actually how you sound when
you yeah you've seen me cry you do the
broken voice like that yeah wow all
right um so i do feel like but don't
touch me there so i do feel the same
thing
yeah don't would your grandpa's name bob
no is that why you're only bob when
you're serious
no i don't know his name [ __ ] him
um
can i say this yeah
everybody that's ever been on the show
have said to me that your fans the tiger
brother fans are the most frank
fanatic fanatic yeah and loyal
you're the greatest
you guys are the greatest people
i'm so
proud
that you're we're a part of each other
i love you guys so [ __ ] much
thank you so much for listening
hey tiger belly crew i live with my
parents i'm a tall asian young guy fresh
out of high school i'm still a virgin in
19 and i want to lose it
hey hey
hey man i'm tall
hey man i'm i'm tall well that doesn't
help nothing's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
not extremely not extremely handsome
but i'm really handsome oh wow
we're gonna choke be careful i'm tall
not extremely handsome but i'm really
handsome i've been told i look like
daniel henny i know for a fact i can get
girls no questions but i have no car and
no girl wants to date a loser with no
car what am i supposed to do bike to her
house
lame my tan is too lazy to teach me how
there's a lot of parentheses here hold
on my dad is too lazy to teach me how to
drive so getting my driver's license is
slow